when you think of a nuclear power plant
you're probably thinking of something
that looks like this
but this small reactor is one of several
Atomic Innovations getting a boost of
new investment
it comes as the war in Ukraine is
sparking a global energy crisis the
energy crisis caused by Putin's law and
as governments try to move away from
high polluting energy sources to meet
emissions targets in recent months these
countries in Europe have all announced
plans to build or invest in new reactors
while the U.S has poured billions into
developing new technology but for
nuclear energy to truly stage a comeback
the industry also needs to address its
long-time troubles from safety issues to
being financially sustainable so a new
crop of startups are saying their design
and Technology can offer new solutions
to Old problems
first we need to look at the issues that
of dog nuclear energy for decades to
find out what this new technology is
trying to solve and that starts with
World War II when scientists harness
atomic energy for nuclear weapons
that's the atomic bomb exploding at
Nagasaki
after the war was over the U.S
government wanted to usher in safer ways
to use the energy source President
Eisenhower wanted to alleviate the
concerns that and the fears that people
had about nuclear technology by
attempting to channel nuclear energy
into peaceful uses so governments and
companies turn to commercial projects
including a nuclear-powered concept for
a family sedan that never came to
fruition but large power plants popped
up across the country
starting in the early 60s descent began
to build as communities became unhappy
about these large structures being
constructed in their backyards
those concerns they resulted in local
opposition some lawsuits citing disputes
around the construction new power plants
those added to the cost of building the
power plants
accident in 1979 grabbed the nation's
attention
[Music]
a partial meltdown of the Three Mile
Island reactor in Pennsylvania spurred a
new wave of nuclear skepticism and
angered residents of the town with the
president of the United States bring his
family and sleep here right here in this
path now other accidents around the
world followed in 1986 a radioactive
plume was sent across Europe following
elapse at the Chernobyl power plant in
the former Soviet Union that led to high
exposure to radiation linked to
long-term health conditions including
leukemia
and in 2011 meltdowns occurred at a
plant in Fukushima Japan following an
earthquake and subsequent tsunami
those safety issues pushed the U.S to
tighten its regulations and led to plant
closures in Germany
despite this history the nuclear
industry has kept pushing to get funding
and expand and the U.S government has
stepped in to support a new generation
of advanced reactors these startups
including Terra power which is backed by
Bill Gates are offering different plans
from using sodium to being mobile but
they're all trying to prove the same
thing that they can be the future of the
nuclear industry one of them is called
New scale and it says its design can
help tackle many of the industry's
issues with this small modular reactor
which has been approved by U.S
Regulators it is a simpler design with
much fewer components Dr Jose Reyes is a
chief technology officer at new scale
who co-founded the company over a decade
ago so instead of the large containment
domes that you've seen in the past we
have a very small containment that that
houses our reactor reactors need to
withstand strong forces to stop the
release of radioactive material new
skills plant will house small reactors
inside vessels like these rather than
housing a large reactor in a containment
Dome like this one the company says its
smaller size helps reduce risk during
the fission process because its module
can withstand pressures 15 times greater
than traditional reactors
new skill says other accidents can be
mitigated by its design in an extreme
event such as an earthquake its reactor
can shut down independently While most
traditional reactors require generator
power to switch off critical pumps and
valves
for the worst case conditions the
reactors will shut themselves down
without any operator action and without
the need to add water to keep it cool
for an unlimited period of time
new skills smaller size is also key to
saving money on construction
traditionally parts are custom made on
site by Specialists for instance two new
units at the voctal plant in Georgia are
priced at 30 billion dollars with the
first expected to take more than 10
years to build
but new skill uses an assembly line
model that helps to standardize the
process so even though the company has
yet to finish building a plant it
estimates it'll take about three to five
years to build at a cost of around three
billion dollars once the modules are
fabricated they can be shipped by truck
rail or barge to the site a completed
site and then you install those modules
however studies highlight potential
hurdles linked to its size one of them
found that even with multiple modules
new skills design produces relatively
small amounts of power compared to the
current nuclear reactor Fleet that can
mean energy from its plants would be
more expensive to buy this chart shows
that power from new skills plant would
cost almost twice as much as the
projected cost of renewable energy in
the future
while a nuclear plant that addresses all
the safety issues and cost concerns has
yet to go online some of the new
generation reactors have begun
Construction in 2021 Terra power
announced it at chosen Wyoming for its
reactor and that it'll bring on workers
from a local coal-fired power plant
scheduled to close new scale says its
first plan in Idaho will be completed in
2029
and the grand opening of that will be
one of the first real tests to put the
technology into practice